hablamos ahora de economía aquí en 24
saludamos de nuevo a daniela blandón que
nos va a contar lo más importante es
tratar de daniela porque hay un nuevo
capítulo en la pelea judicial por la
reforma eléctrica en méxico si liliana
la de nuevo pues el tema se volvió una
disputa judicial entre el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador y
el juez juan pablo gómez fierro este
último había ordenado la suspensión
provisional de la polémica ley ya
aprobada por el congreso el mandatario
amenazó con promover un cambio en la
constitución si su proyecto se enredaban
los tribunales y exigió una
investigación a este juez es ahora el
mismo que en la frenada definitivamente
a través de un llamado incidente de
suspensión al menos hasta que el poder
judicial se pronuncia al respecto gómez
hierro argumenta que busca proteger los
derechos de libre competencia el asunto
es el siguiente la ley es controversial
porque básicamente prioriza el despacho
de las generadoras estatales de
electricidad sin importar si su fuente
es renovable o no sobre las privadas
muchas de las cuales si son
desde que llegó al poder en 2018 andrés
manuel lópez obrador prometió revertir
parte de la reforma energética de su
predecesor enrique peña nieto quien
abrió el sector a la participación
privada
daniela italia aprobó un nuevo paquete
de ayudas en medio de un nuevo
confinamiento por kobe 19 este país se
endureció las restricciones hasta el 6
de abril para contener los contagios
ahora lanza un plan por valor de 32 mil
millones de euros con el que busca
ayudar a la recuperación económica en
una de las naciones más golpeadas por la
crisis del cobi 19 el gobierno explicó
que tres cuartas partes de estos
recursos irán destinadas a las empresas
una parte destinada al resto oro hoy hay
una parte destinada a indemnizaciones
para empresas que operan en la montaña
seguía operar la montaña hay mucha parte
de este decreto dirigido al turismo y
una parte importante para los autónomos
incluidos los trabajadores del sector
agrícola clues y laboratorio del sector
agrícola marina y rusia le pone freno a
sus exportaciones para proteger la
demanda
liliana como le parece que rusia es uno
de los principales exportadores de
alimentos del mundo y también es el
mayor vendedor de trigo con la escases
de alimentos generada por la pandemia
sus precios comenzaron a subir en 2020
lo hicieron en un 8% con las mayores
alzas en el azúcar las frutas el pan y
los cereales ante la situación el
gobierno decidió reducir las cuotas
permitidas de exportación de cereales
para que los productos se queden en el
mercado interno también aumentó los
aranceles sobre las ventas por lo menos
hasta finales de junio en américa
latina' los afectados con esta medida
serían países como méxico y venezuela
que son los que más le compran trigo a
este país
daniela ya turismo dominicano ves signos
de recuperación un año después del
cierre total pues el año pasado el
número de turistas en república
dominicana bajó a niveles de 1998 apenas
recibió 2,4 millones de turistas cuando
en 2019 había recibido tres veces más
justo hoy se cumple un año desde que
entró en vigor la suspensión de vuelos
que llevó a tres
y medio de playas vacías y pérdidas
millonarios y aunque las fronteras se
reabrieron en julio el efecto de la
pandemia todavía se siente sin embargo
ahora son más optimistas que antes con
las reservas hoteleras de marzo se
proyecta una ocupación del 41% en el mes
el mejor promedio en los últimos doce
meses en puntacana que es el destino
principal del país la reserva de
habitaciones ya volvió a niveles pre
pandemia según el ministerio de turismo
esto a pesar de que canadá prohibió los
viajes de sus ciudadanos al caribe hasta
abril y este es el segundo país que más
turistas envía a la nación caribeña
daniela y cuéntenos cómo están para hoy
los indicadores de la jornada liliana
wall street' de cerró la semana mixto la
acción de facebook subió más del 4 por
ciento a pesar de la interrupción
temporal de sus aplicaciones incluidos
también whatsapp e instagram a nivel
mundial europa cerró con pérdidas en
especial frankfurt
fráncfort o parís y madrid y en américa
latina las bolsas también se tiñeron de
rojo y la cifra el día daniela 1250
millones de dólares que aprobará el este
año para colombia en préstamos
destinados al crecimiento verde
transformación digital y apoyo para los
migrantes venezolanos gracias por la
información de economía ni el año este
de gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24 quédense para ver madures a
programación y también visiten brass 24
punto com
[Música]